the fact that he was the most Google
person and everything he did was get 100
million views and they're just scared of
any any man that pops up that threatens
their Monopoly because what might stand
up against the globalist or take over
the planet men and so any man they can't
buy any man they can't intimidate any
man they can't destroy they come after
you with sex and let me just tell you I
think he did some racy stuff they did
the cam stuff they made a lot of money
he had a former police officers and
people running it uh that that's his
right to do it I I think he painted a
Target on his back but I don't think he
knew how big he was going to get and
that that would then happen